today on the matt welsh show usa today
commits the most egregious form
of orwellian speech manipulation that i
think maybe we've
seen yet you have to hear hear it to
believe it and we'll we'll talk about
that in a second
also five headlines including a new
study which seems to show that mask
mandates did
absolutely nothing to slow the spread of
covet who would have thought
and a white journalist is put on the
spot in an interview when he's asked
what he likes about being white it's an
interesting exchange we'll play that
today also
a new proposal from maxine waters to
give down payment assistance to
americans to help them buy their first
homes
but of course not all americans will get
help especially not white americans
we'll talk about that and much more
today on the matt walsh show
[Music]
chelsea mitchell is a name that you may
or may not know she would be a household
name if we lived in a country
and a culture where strong and brave
women were actually celebrated
we're told of course that such women are
celebrated we're instructed to celebrate
them
but it turns out that there's only a
very specific type of female bravery
that we're supposed to recognize and
honor
in fact according to our cultural
overlords the most honorable act
of female bravery is that which is
committed by males
trans women quote unquote are the most
acclaimed sort of women in the country
today
and they aren't really women at all real
women take a back seat
and real women who oppose the intrusion
of so-called trans women
quote unquote aren't simply sent to the
back they're kicked off of the bus
entirely
that's been the case for chelsea
mitchell who along with three other
female athletes is suing the connecticut
intercollect
interscholastic athletic conference for
allowing males
to compete against them you may have
heard of this case
almost everyone in the country today
would claim to stand for the rights of
women
right everybody would say that but few
have had the courage to remain standing
when push really comes to shove mitchell
and her fellow plaintiffs
are among the few who are actually
standing up for women
and they have all of our cultural
institutions especially the media
stacked against them
that point was made abundantly clear
this week after mitchell wrote an op-ed
for usa today
where she's making her case making her
case against males competing against
females in sports
now the fact that usa today would even
publish that article in the first place
may seem like an encouraging sign but
that encouraging sign quickly
turned creepy and orwellian before we
get there let's let's read some of what
mitchell wrote in her editorial
or i should say this was her original
editorial
as it first appeared this is what she
says
uh quote it's february 2020. i'm
crouched to the starting line of the
high school girls 55 meter indoor race
this should be one of the best days of
my life i'm running in the state
championship and i'm ranked the fastest
high school female
in the 55 meter dash in the state i
should be feeling confident
i should know that i have a strong shot
at winning instead all i can think about
is how all my training
everything i've done to maximize my
performance might not be enough
simply because there's a runner on the
line with an enormous physical advantage
a male body
i won that race and i'm grateful but
time after time
i have lost i've lost four women's state
championship titles
two all new england awards and numerous
other spots on the podium to male
runners i was bumped to third place in
the 55 meter dash in 2019
behind two male runners with every loss
it gets harder and harder to try
to try again that's a devastating
experience it tells me that i'm not good
enough that my body isn't good enough
no matter how hard i work i'm like i'm
unlikely
unlikely to succeed because i'm a woman
that experiences why three of my fellow
female athletes and i filed a lawsuit
last year with
alliance defending freeman against
freedom against the connecticut
interscholastic
athletic conference because girls and
women shouldn't be stripped of their
right to fair competition
okay now everything that she's written
here
so far is factually correct
morally correct inarguable
inarguable i would say she's a woman she
was forced to compete against people who
are not women
they had unfair advantages because of
their male bodies
through those unfair advantages she was
robbed of the achievements that she had
earned
this is an utterly unassailable and
undeniable point
she also describes and i want to read
this because um it
she talks about how bad the situation
has gotten
it's actually worse than i even realized
she says quote the ciac allows
biological males to compete in girls and
women's sports
as a result two males began racing in
girls track in 2017
in the 2017 2018 and 2019 seasons alone
these males took 15 women's state track
championship titles
titles held in 2016 by nine different
girls
and more than 85 opportunities to
participate in higher level competitions
that belong to female track athletes
that's because males have massive
physical advantages their bodies are
simply bigger and stronger on average
than female bodies it's obvious to every
single girl
on the track all right 15 titles
two males took 15 titles that before
have been split between nine different
girls
and these are males who we should
remember wouldn't have even
made it onto the track in a championship
meet against other males these were
mediocre unimpressive male athletes
who couldn't hack it against the boys
and yet they dominated against the girls
and by the way we we can't see inside
their minds we don't know their
motivation
but i'm gonna guess i'm gonna speculate
that this is not a coincidence
it's not a coincidence that they found
that they were mediocre and
they couldn't really compete against the
boys and then they discovered their
female identity
what do you know what a what a fortunate
coincidence
can't compete against the guys turns out
i'm a girl well
here we go i don't know but i'm gonna
say
probably not a coincidence
and why do they have that event well
because the male body confers enormous
advantages in athletic competitions
against females with female bodies
which are the only kinds of females that
exist chelsea mitchell's point is that
no matter how these boys identify
no matter how they feel no matter their
perception of themselves
the biological facts remain
and all that matters in a track meet are
the facts
especially the biological facts the
physical facts that's one of the great
things about
running as a sport i ran track when i
was in high school
and one of the things i like about it is
that it's it's it's
mono imano very very simple
can i get to the finish line before you
that's all it comes down to
all that matters are the physical facts
am i stronger than you am i faster do i
have more endurance
and we're going to find out because
whoever crosses the finish line first
that's the answer
um what doesn't really matter are your
feelings
so if you have a biological advantage
over somebody else on the track
that advantage is not offset by your
feelings or your self-perception
and that's the case that mitchell makes
or made anyway in usa today
that was until trans activists read her
piece and realizing that they could make
no
intellectual argument against it
resorted to their favorite tactic which
is silencing the opposition
and they especially enjoy silencing
women
i mean no nobody no group in america
more aggressively silences women than
trans activists
it's not even close
but if they want to silence women they
can't do that without the acquiescence
of cowards in positions of power so they
complained
that the article hurt their feelings and
usa today with little resistance on
their part or pushback
summarily changed the article after
publication
and without notifying the author that
they were doing it
they just changed it in order to remove
all quote hurtful language from it
now as you recall let's go back again
read this one little paragraph again in
the original article
as written by chelsea mitchell which was
originally published in usa today this
is what it said
again quote instead all i could think
about is all my training everything i've
done to maximize my performance
might not be enough simply because
there's a runner on the line with an
enormous physical advantage
a male body remember that okay after usa
today made post-publication editorial
changes to appease
radical trans activists it now says
instead all i can think about is how all
my training everything i've done to
maximize my performance might not be
enough
simply because there's a transgender
runner on the line with an enormous
physical advantage
you spot the difference kind of hard to
miss they remove the word male
whereas before she says that the runner
had the advantage of a male body
now it simply says that the transgender
runner
had an advantage what kind of advantage
well who knows maybe he was wearing more
comfortable socks that day
maybe she ate a cheeseburger before the
race and he didn't
all mention of the specific type of
advantage has been erased indeed
usa today removed the word mail from the
entire article
and didn't even acknowledge that they'd
done it aside from an editor's note
apologizing for their hurtful language
and in this case the hurtful language
again was scientifically correct
language
and it was also the entire point of the
article
mitchell's original piece says the word
male 10 times
every other sentence practically
contains the word male because
that's the entire point and premise
is no argument against trans runners in
female sports
except for the fact that they're male
that's it there's no other argument
that's that's the only one
and it's all you need in fact the
argument
has nothing to do with the fact that
they're trans
that's irrelevant their self per
trans is self perception
their self perception is irrelevant the
whole point the only point
the point is that they are male usa
today decided that it's happy to
publish her argument as long as her
argument
doesn't contain her actual argument
is quite clearly to my mind one of the
most egregious and outlandish cases of
media bias and orwellian speech
manipulation
that we've yet seen and it really
matters
this is more than just some dumb thing
that we can roll our eyes about and say
oh there's the silly mainstream media
up to its old tricks again now this is
the kind of thing that
influences people the goal
is pretty clear it's to make it seem as
though the people who are opposed to
males and female sports or
or female locker rooms are really just
opposed to trans people and we hear this
kind of
um this is the way the media presents it
all the time the only difference is that
usually they don't they don't make a
change post-publication
in most cases the original thing they
publish is going to be framed exactly
like
the uh edited version of chelsea
mitchell's piece where they say things
like
you see all kinds of headlines like this
that uh you know conservatives are
opposed to
trans people and sports or there's a
bill being passed in texas or
or wherever uh uh that that
will ban trans people from sports that's
not the case
that's not the case at all it's it's not
about trans
um the average oblivious american
who reads that okay they're going to
read that and think well what's the
problem here
who cares if the other runner is trans
when in reality
it's chelsea mitchell who doesn't care
if they're trans
they can identify as however they want
it's the biological reality that matters
and the goal of the left with a big
assist from the media
is to erase that biological reality
now in truth they can never actually
erase
a reality biology will remain biology no
matter
what anyone says about it or feels in
relation to it but
they can create a society that
fundamentally fails to recognize
or is hostile to reality
and unfortunately towards that end they
are succeeding
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well as we just i think made made clear
um in the opening there the this the the
country seems to be getting crazier and
crazier
by the day and uh that's certainly not
helped by the fact that
all of our cultural institutions and
most
powerful companies are against us as
conservatives in the culture and that's
why one thing we can do
to reclaim the culture is when we find
companies that are on our side we should
support them
uh and join them and that's why you got
to try out charity mobile charity mobile
is the pro-life phone company five
percent of your monthly plan price goes
to the pro-life pro family charity of
your choice
and what that means is that whenever you
pay your bill you're
also helping to build a culture of life
in america uh
by supporting a pro-life phone company
you can turn everyday living into
effortless giving
but on top of that it's it's a it's an
awesome service um
and listen new activations and eligible
accounts get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping
there's no contracts there's no
termination fees there's no risk with a
30-day guarantee
we also have live customer service which
i think is great based right here
in the usa whenever you need them so you
have to go to charity mobile call them
at 1-877-474-3662
you also chat with them online at
charitymobile.com new lower monthly plan
prices and a new plan with a higher data
limit
is available existing customers
automatically get the newer lower lower
plan prices no need to contact them and
ask for them again charitymobile.com
well i don't know if you tuned in to
backstage last night we had our
backstage
uh monthly backstage show
and fortunately i think for the first
hour it was uh you know there's a lot of
boring stuff about
things happening on the globe on the on
the earth who cares about that
but all that anyone really cares about
is what's happening in outer space well
i'll talk about the space aliens
so finally we did talk about the space
aliens if you didn't watch well you know
what
if you didn't watch the episode um i
would say you you don't even really need
to watch it
because what i can tell you is that many
people are saying
many people are saying that um i
utterly demolished everybody else on the
subject of aliens
and i was outnumbered clavin
turns out is is he's sort of alien
curious
um he's alien questioning he's open to
it
alien fluid maybe but ben jeremy michael
very anti-alien and so i was
really there and the other thing that
many people are saying and who's saying
this again many people
the other thing many people are saying
is that um they were stunned frankly by
my
bravery um as a marginalized identity as
a as a as an alien believing american
aba abba
is what we call ourselves i've decided
um so as the only abba
on the stage a marginalized identity in
in in an unsafe environment
but uh i i did i wiped the floor i think
i
i basically proved
not only that aliens exist in the
universe but that they are visiting
earth and as i said you don't need to
even watch it i would say
don't watch it because there's no point
just take my word for it
actually after the the show concluded
and i shouldn't even be talking about
this but
the other three ben jeremy michael they
were they were they they were leaving in
tears
um and they were saying that they were
afraid that i embarrassed them
because my arguments were so good in
comparison to their weak arguments and
uh
so it's a pretty emotional moment no
need to confirm any of what i'm saying
right now
just trust me on this all right um
and uh let's go number one from from
town hall this is uh this
should be like breaking news even though
it's not a surprise
perhaps to to many of us it says new
findings reported tuesday in a
university of louisville study
challenge what has been the prevailing
belief that mask mandates are necessary
to slow the spread
of the wuhan chronovirus the study notes
that 80 percent
of u.s states mandated masks during the
kova 19 pandemic
and while mandates induced greater mass
compliance
they didn't predict lower growth rates
when community spread was low or high
among other things the study conducted
using data from the cdc covering
multiple seasons reports that mask
mandates in use
are not associated with lower coveted
spread among u.s states
quote our findings do not support the
hypothesis
that transmission rates decrease with
greater
public mass use researchers stated that
masks
may promote social cohesion as rallying
symbols during a pandemic
but risk compensation can also occur
because uh because um okay let me read
here from
quoting from the actual study now
it says prolonged mass use around four
hours a day
promotes facial alkalinization
and i certainly know what that means and
inadvertently encourages dehydration
which in turn can enhance
barrier breakdown and bacterial
infection risk british clinicians
have reported masks to increase
headaches and sweating
and decrease cognitive precision survey
bias notwithstanding these
are associated with medical errors by
obscuring non-verbal communication masks
interfere with social learning in
children
likewise masks can distort verbal speech
and remove visual cues to the detriment
of individuals with hearing loss
and then it goes on from there um
in summary okay i'll continue reading a
little bit mass mandates and use for
poor predictors of coven 19 spread in
u.s states case growth was independent
of mandates at low and high rates of
community spread
and mass queues did not predict case
growth during these summer or fall
winter waves
uh strengths of our study include using
two mask metrics to evaluate association
with cop19 growth rates
etc and so forth this is this is what
the study says is what the research says
um i who knows maybe youtube will still
ban this episode because i'm just
reading what the study says
but this is what i keep going back to
it it's good to get the scientific data
and i'm glad that finally we're getting
some studies and we're getting some
some science on some of these issues but
at the same time
this is a this is common sense
this was common sense to a lot of us
things like forcing people to wear masks
all day for hours at a time
most of us to begin with we knew that
you know medical masks were never
designed
or never intended for that kind of use
to be an
everyday accessory that you just put on
your face all day
and walk around everywhere with
just as a common sense judgment before
looking at any data
people with common sense should know
that there are going to be problems
there
yeah you can have dehydration it's going
to it's going to make you hotter it's
it's uh
it doesn't seem very sanitary
you have germs and sweat and everything
and it also and for and for kids
taking aside even all the physical
problems
it seems there are psychological and
emotional problems especially for
children forcing them to wear masks all
the time
depriving them of the ability to see the
faces of other people
it creates social problems even among
adults trying to communicate with people
and you can't even see their faces
faces
and all the while you know uh the what
we're being told is that putting this
piece of cloth on your face is going to
provide you
significant protection against these
microscopic um
you know this this microscopic virus
i don't know again common sense
there would seem to be some serious
questions that you might ask about about
that
but you weren't allowed to ask the
questions
you're not allowed to make common sense
judgments
you have to wait until the experts tell
you
now with the masking thing we know with
uh the wuhan
lab in china finally the experts
and the media who all of them consider
themselves to be experts
they're finally telling us that okay
it's okay now you're allowed to draw
this connection you're allowed to
speculate
about what seems like the very real and
likely possibility that this came from a
lab in china you're allowed to do that
for the last year you weren't allowed to
do that
because we hadn't told you yet that
you're allowed to have that opinion but
now we've decided that you're allowed to
have that opinion
will we get to that point with masks i
don't know
um i i kind of in my in my head i kind
of go back and forth on this
are masks here to stay at least in some
places in america forever
that seems very very likely very
possible um
or you know it's also just as possible i
suppose
that the media who knows they could do
it tomorrow or next month
they could just decide that oh you know
what never mind not supposed to wear
masks anymore
and in fact they could decide all of a
sudden that not only are you not
supposed to wear them but if you do wear
them
you're a maniac you're anti-science and
all of this
it's all but it's all up to them they
decide and we follow along
the main thing though the main lesson is
do not use your own brain
don't try to sort through these things
on your own
don't look at the data and draw your own
conclusions
don't listen to what they're saying and
try to
point to holes in their logic don't do
any of that
just be a good and cooperative little
boy or girl
or whatever and uh and do as you're told
all right number two journalist chris
ruffo who's been
on the critical race theory beat for
last year or two and it's done
i think easily one of the most important
journalists in america now that's kind
of a low bar because there aren't
very many journalists at all that are
doing real journalism but he's one of
the ones
doing real journalism especially when it
comes to critical race theory
uh he was invited on a show with mark
lamont hill i'm not sure what show this
is black
news tonight okay that's the name of the
show on
i don't know what network but anyway at
the end of the interview
there's what i think is a really
interesting exchange so let's uh let's
just start watching this
and if i were to say to you right now
christopher what do you like about being
white what would you say
i don't know again it's such an
amorphous term it's like a census term
or a
can can you can you indulge me in
indulge me for once
just we're running out of time indulge
me for a minute i understand you see it
as as all these things but
you surely recognize that the world sees
you as white you know the world reads
you as white
and if you were to ask me some things i
like about being black i could talk
about cultural norms i could talk about
tradition i could talk about
the kind of commonalities i feel around
the diaspora if i were to ask you what
particularly if you're saying whiteness
is a thing that is being constructed as
negative and shouldn't be
name name something positive that you
like about being white
well sure i i you know i'll i'll answer
with uh with a thing there
there's a lot of documents that are
floating around public schools that say
things like
uh timeliness showing up on time is a
white supremacist value or a white value
white dominant value things like
rationality things like the
enlightenment
things like uh you know objectivity
and these are very strange things to be
ascribed to a racial identity my view is
that these are
actually should be ascribed to every
individual human being every individual
human being regardless of whatever
racial category we impose on them
that doesn't answer that that doesn't
answer the question no you're telling
you're
you're telling me you're making
strongmen about things that are ascribed
to whiteness that you think are
wrongfully ascribed to whiteness i'm
saying if whiteness isn't a negative
thing
and there's something that you actually
and that whiteness actually shouldn't be
constructed as all negative
name something positive about being that
you believe is positive about being
white
again i don't buy into the framework
that the world can be reduced into these
metaphysical categories of whiteness and
blackness i think that's wrong i think
we should look at people as individuals
i think we should celebrate
uh different people's accomplishments
and uh again i think the idea you you
mentioned ignatia if not you says the
goal is to quote
abolish the white race um in any other
context this would be interpreted as a
near
genocidal slur i don't buy into it the
reason i'm not going to answer your
question
is i reject that categorization i think
of myself as an individual human being
with my own capabilities and i would
hope that we could both judge each other
as individuals
and come to common values on that basis
okay so it seems like a lot of people on
the right this this
video is being shared yesterday kind of
went viral in fact mark lamont hill is
quite proud of this exchange and he's
the one who who originally
put it on twitter i don't know if very
many people would have seen it
had he not and a lot of people on the
right were
upset about the question and were saying
that it's kind of a racist question
which which it is um because of
of what's being implied kind of in a
vacuum just saying
what do you like about being white and
that's not necessarily a racist question
but
the implication the insinuation from uh
mark lamont hill
is that it's bad to be white so
you could almost it it's what he was
really asking is
what could you possibly like about being
white which is a racist question
but um it's also a smart strategy
it's a smart tactic and it's the kind of
thing you're going to step into the ring
with someone like
like hill you have to be prepared for
that and i and i and i thought chris
ruffalo handled it
handled it well i thought he handed it
really well i'm not saying he wasn't
prepared
but it is it's it's a it is a clever
trick
for mark lamont hill because what's the
point well the point is
if if you refuse to answer
what you like about being white then
hill can say you've proved his point
that well you can't even you're white
you can't even say anything you like
about being like apparently being white
is a bad thing
but if you answer the question and say
well here's
i'll give you a list here's 20 things i
love about being white now you're a
white supremacist
and uh and people and and hill knows
that this is what would happen
people are gonna come in they're gonna
they're gonna they'll take the question
out but that
because context doesn't matter we know
that especially with the racial
uh the race hustlers the context never
matters whether it's a police shooting
or anything else
so it just creates almost like this mean
template for people to come in
take the question aside get rid of all
the context and then take
just that 20 second clip
which starts with you saying what i like
about being white is xyz
and then that lives for in forever in
infamy uh on the internet
as proof that you're a white supremacist
so that's the trick
that's the ploy it's a clever one
it's pretty despicable but it's also
clever as a as just a strategy
um i think what what chris ruffalo is
doing there
he's rejecting the framework he's saying
i'm not going to play that game with you
perfectly good way of doing it
um one other strategy though
could be to to turn it around
if you can put the other guy on the
defensive
and you could ask you you could say to
mark lamont hill well
what do you why are you asking me that
question that's a really strange
question to ask
can can you name anything good about
being white
are you assuming that there's nothing
good about being white white is who i am
part of my identity it's part of who i
am
are you saying there's nothing good
about that part of my identity
can you name anything good about being
white
i i would like to see how he would
handle that
because maybe he could list a few things
but you know he
if he lists a couple of uh of positive
things which you probably wouldn't then
you could say okay yeah and that's what
i like about being white too
but he probably wouldn't be able to do
that no he wouldn't be willing to
and so you've put him in a position
where he's saying well i don't see
anything good about
being white which of course is
incredibly racist
so all you're doing is proving that he's
a racist that he can't see anything good
that's why he's asking the question
again what's implied and not said is
what could you
possibly like about being white
so that's another way of doing it is to
is to flip it around
or you know third option um
mark lamont hill said if you ask me what
i like about being black i would say
uh cultural norms tradition heritage
well you could you could easily say okay
well that's what i like about being
white
or i mean unless you're going to tell me
that only white people aren't allowed to
like those things about themselves
are you saying that you're allowed to to
like
culture tradition your heritage as a
person
feeling proud of your ancestors and
where you came from
are you saying that you're allowed to be
proud of that and happy about that and
like that and i'm not
so there's a there's a number of
different ways to go about it i think
that chris chris
ruffo handled it pretty well um
but you just know of course it's not an
honest question
it's this is not this is not an attempt
to really
understand at all this is an attempt to
trap and you know that going in
all right um number three
okay i got to read this is from the
sunday express i hate to go back to ufos
actually i don't but i just want to read
this to you very briefly
it says that i don't know what the
sunday express is
let's just assume they're a reputable
news source the u.s navy has picked up
sonar data showing mysterious
fast-moving objects
underwater that cannot be explained
by experts or current technology
washington examiner's tom rogan said the
us navy
has the data to prove the bizarre
encounters some of these encounters
could be
included in the u.s government task
force which is preparing to brief
congress on its ufo findings next month
this comes amid a flurry of footage
showing bizarre encounters between u.s
pilots and navy officers and
unexplainable objects so
now we've got uh you know under
unidentified flying objects but that's
not this because they're underwater so i
guess unidentified
swimming objects the uso well that
acronym is already taken but
now you have um objects underwater as
well that are unexplained
and you know we we do know very little
about our oceans or what's happening
down there
could there be civilizations living
under the ocean
it's possible here's here's problem
that's probably not the case
at all um so i'm not quite ready to come
out as a believer in aquaman
but i will say and i think somewhat
someone brought this up in the youtube
comments yesterday the thing about
civilizations under the ocean but it is
inter here's what
you talk about the oceans and we live on
the earth
alongside the ocean and yet we we know
very little about it so much of it is
unexplored
that probably doesn't mean that there's
atlantis down there somewhere
but it's fascinating to think about just
how little we know
and um and that explains if anyone's
wondering that is my
personal fascination with ufos and
aliens and everything
uh just because we we know so little
about
outer space we we know
you could fill a thimble really with
what we know about it
in comparison to how vast of an expanse
it actually is i mean it's essentially
infinite for all intents and purposes
uh and that to me is uh is is just
fascinating to think to think of the
possibilities
and i don't understand how people could
be could fail to be fascinated by that
or bored by the discussion
um all right number four
this uh photo's been floating around for
a couple of days i just want to show
this to you
the website pop crave shared a photo of
ellen page
now elliott page um
and here's the the picture if you
haven't seen um there's elliott page
shirtless breasts removed uh there's
been some speculation that there are
some ab implants going on there
i think there might be something to that
speculation but putting that aside i
don't know
you see a photo like this we're supposed
to applaud this
but it's it's it's it's actually
intensely sad and disturbing
this is a person that has totally
rejected themselves
this is self mutilation
you know applauding a picture like this
it is no
different from seeing an emaciated
anorexic
and applauding that and saying oh
doesn't she look fantastic
she looks beautiful she's uh she looks
exactly how she wants to look she's
living her truth
living out her identity yeah she's
destroying her body but uh it's a
beautiful thing
in fact i don't have to that's not even
really a hypothetical
we're already doing that with not with
maybe not anorexics but people are
morbidly obese it's the same kind of
thing
we see a morbidly obese person
destroying themselves
and uh we're supposed to applaud it and
it's the same sort of thing here
a woman who has chopped off
parts of her body
foreclosed entire biological
functions permanently
and were meant to applaud that that uh
that i
i certainly could never do i
i i find it sad and i'm i'm moved with
the pity
honestly when i see photos like that
i don't understand how you could have
any other reaction
all right finally number five i
mentioned this briefly a few days ago i
never got to it but
it's this is from buzzfeed it says in a
national effort to get through to horny
but vaccinate
vaccine hesitant americans the white
house announced friday that it is
joining forces with dating apps to
encourage people
to get their cover 19 vaccines so that
so that they can go
forth and f freely this summer this is a
that's not the language from the white
house but this is the language in a
buzzfeed news article
i want to talk about where what's
happened with the american journalism
there you go
vaccinated users on tinder hinge bumble
and badoo
i haven't even heard of most of these
apps well tinder i know about bumble
hinge they will have access to some
premium features for free
okay cupid chispa blk
and match are giving out a free boost to
those who've been vaccinated so that
their profiles are more likely to be
seen first
plenty of fish is also offering free
credits to vaccinated members
for its live streaming feature uh and so
the idea is to get people
you know a lot of these i guess are not
so much apps people use to
find other individuals to have
relationships with but more just hookup
apps so
i guess and that's really the good news
here is that
um when you're when you're hooking up
with random strangers that you meet on
an app
and you just learned their name an hour
ago and already you're in bed with them
yeah the good thing is that the only
disease
or negative outcome you ever had to
worry about was covet
and so now i guess we're hearing from
the white house just get that cova
vaccine
throw caution to the wind again what
could possibly go wrong
except for everything as we've seen in
society of the last several decades
all right let's move now to reading the
youtube comments um
major tom fisher says holy crap i think
i might actually be slightly moderately
maybe intrigued a tiny bit by the wnba
if there are six foot eight inch women
in it
where the heck do you find women that
tall
yeah that is that is
pretty fascinating in a way but the
thing is they still can't dunk
which is kind of sad unidentified
unidentifiable reviewer says matt walsh
react to the menendez brothers trial
case it's all over tik tok
i see this a lot in the comments where
people are trying to get me to talk
about something
and uh and so they they always mention
as a qualifier oh you know they're
talking about this on tik tok
because they know of my tic toc
obsession so if you want to get me to
talk about it all you have to do is
mention that
the cool kids are talking about tic toc
and it worked here too
i don't know a lot i i'm i'm vaguely
aware there's something going on going
on with this and there's some sort of
on internet trend the min so i i guess i
really shouldn't be talking about it at
all uh because i i don't i know almost
nothing about it
i do know the menendez brothers they
were 30 years ago or something was a
famous case of these brothers
who i think were both teenagers at the
time maybe one was in his early 20s
and they they killed their parents in a
horrific and brutal crime including i
think
they shot their their mother multiple
times
with like a shotgun and they went to
jail
forever no possibility of parole
and what we were told by prosecutors is
that they had done this
in order to collect life insurance from
their parents because their parents were
really wealthy
so this is all this is all a plot to
make money off their parents
and now sort of randomly
two or three decades later i think
people on tick tock are kind of
reopening this case
at least online in their own way and
and uh saying that these brothers should
be freed from from prison
not because they were innocent but
because they claim that um
the menendez brothers were being
sexually abused and so that this was
them sort of in an act of self-defense
or after years of abuse
uh they just had enough of it and i
don't know if that's true or not i don't
know anything about it
if it were true let's just say i mean
hypothetically and i have no idea if
that's the case if this is the case here
if it were true i
took it in a hypothetical case you've
got kids who were
sexually abused by their parents for
years
and finally after years of this they
killed their parents
um yes i would i would not give someone
in that case
life in prison without parole i'd be
looking at more of like a manslaughter
charge or something
is that the case here i've i have no
clue at all
so that is my analysis i hope it lived
up to your expectations i'm sure that it
didn't
um and finally
another comment says the holocaust isn't
even the greatest atrocity of the 20th
century mao's cultural revolution and
stalin's purges slash gulags come to
mind
throughout history there have been many
events worse in the holocaust genghis
khan and his crew were responsible for
so many deaths
that the global temperature dropped like
there's there's no
you get to a certain level of atrocity
and there's no point in ranking them
okay when you get to people do this
sometimes
who who was the greater villain of the
20th century stalin or hitler
um stalin is responsible for more deaths
i think that's
pretty inarguable but who's more evil
they're equal
in like as as evil as a person can
possibly be
they both reached that level they both
plund
plunged to that depth i think we could
say um
though it is it is funny that you that
um
if you i think if you compared something
when you talked about how
marjorie taylor green got into so much
trouble because she made a holocaust
analogy
even though the left they make holocaust
and hitler analogies all the time
but if you compare something to almost
any other historical atrocity
even probably more recent ones you're
not going to get the same outraged
reaction
as you would with a holocaust analogy if
you're someone on the right and again if
you're on the left then you can get
you can say whatever you want but i
think a lot of this comes down
simply to historical ignorance um and
that's one of the reasons why
people always go right to the holocaust
analogy the hitler analogy
it's not anti-semitism that that charge
doesn't even make any sense
but this this comes simply from i think
in
a lot of cases historical ignorance the
holocaust is
is one of the only historical events
that people these days especially have
been through the public school system
actually know anything about and even
with that i mean these are not experts
on world war ii
but they know in broad strokes that this
happened and that it was a terrible
thing
and i think that's why hitler comes up
so much
even in cases when they're you know
depending on the point trying to be made
there might be another historical
villain who's a bret who's a better
analog but
most people don't know about those other
people
i i don't think you can overstate the
historical ignorance in america today
it's a big problem
you see all these man on the street
interviews which are really funny and we
could all have fun with them
where you go to a college campus and you
and you you know you have a
camera phone or a microphone and a
camera a camera phone
and uh you know you ask college students
questions like
what century did the civil war happen in
and they have no idea
and we all laugh about that and it is
funny but it's also
terrifying you have entire generations
of americans who know
nothing about their own history men are
then are very easily manipulated as
we've seen
i get messages and emails every day many
of them
asking if the daily wire is hiring and
uh can
can i can i hire them for this or that
position the thing is i'm not in charge
of that or anything around here
but i can tell you because i have it on
the sheet of paper here's some
information
that has been given to me to tell you
the daily wire has several open
positions for in-house
our in-house team in nashville and this
week we're highlighting the opening for
an accounts payable associate
whatever that is this person will be
responsible for oh here we know
we know now it's for the day-to-day
accounts payable functions in our
finance department
we're looking for someone with at least
three years of previous professional
accounts payable experience
familiarity with bookkeeping and basic
accounting procedures are key for this
role
our ideal candidate is also highly
organized and has a strong has strong
attention to detail
basically it's not me okay i am the
wrong i'm personally the wrong person
for this which is why i do what i do
but if you want this job it's a
full-time in-office position in
nashville and candidates can apply
through dailywire.com career so go there
now
and if you haven't entered to win yet
while you're there at dailywire.com
uh if you haven't entered to win our
daily wire studio
uh tour to meet candace owens yet then
you still have a chance this is your
final chance to do it it's your last
chance to sign up as a daily wire member
with code
vip you can get 20 off your new
membership and be automatically entered
for a chance to win a trip
to the daily wire studios to see candace
live the sweepstakes ends on monday may
31st
so time is running out you only got a
few days go now not only will you meet
candace you also get an inside look at
her studio and front row seats to watch
her live
and in action on her talk show candace
you're not gonna get another chance
to do this so don't sleep on it go enter
now to win two vip tickets to get a
a candice vip pass at dailywire.com
subscribe using code vip for 20
off now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation maxine
waters enters the ring it may seem
surprising maxine waters has been
canceled i think maybe only once
or twice in this segment before she
could of course be canceled every day
and that explains why she rarely is it'd
be sort of redundant to cancel her every
time she deserves it
we have to pick our spots the thing
about representative maxine waters is
that she is equal parts stupid evil and
racist
and this can make it especially
difficult to figure out whether any
particular thing she does or says or
policy she proposes
was motivated more by her stupidity her
wickedness or her racism
often it's an equal and equitable mix of
all three i think that's probably the
case here
waters has proposed a plan to give
americans
some help in making a down payment on
their first homes
this may or may not sound like a good
idea to you at first blush
but before you draw any conclusions you
have to remember this is maxine waters
we're talking about here this is the
modern democrat party we're talking
about
their plans to help americans are never
plans to help
all americans that's why as a politico
headline puts it the real purpose of
this proposal is to quote close the
racial wealth gap
of course everything is always racial
for these people just as there's only
ever six degrees of separation between
any
hollywood actor and kevin bacon there's
only ever at least
or most two degrees of separation
between any democratic policy proposal
and their racial obsessions it always
comes back to that always
so let's read now from the political
article to get the gist of this plan
it says a 10 billion proposal by house
financial services chair
maxine waters would get would give home
buyers up to 25 000
for a down payment president joe biden's
top housing official hud secretary
marcia fudge
which is just a great name for a
bureaucrat
says such assistance is a priority for
the administration
okay pausing there for a second 10
billion dollars
well what's 10 billion dollars between
friends
there are reports this morning that
biden is about to unveil a six
trillion dollar budget six trillion
dollars
now as ben pointed out on twitter six
trillion is actually 12 trillion when
you factor in the covet stimulus
his family's plan etc
that's all of the proposed spending in
just six months
he's proposing an average of twelve two
trillion dollars a month he has proposed
on average
by the end of his tenure at this rate
he'll have spent
i don't know what 96 trillion dollars if
my math is right which it probably isn't
either way the fact remains these are
astronomical amounts of money these are
such large amounts of money
that you can't even really call them
amounts of money
these numbers are so large they
effectively don't exist
there's no way to conceptualize them
biden is spending money as if there is
no such thing as money
i would say spending money like it grows
on trees but we need more trees than
exist on earth to harvest this much
so 10 billion dollars that is pocket
change i suppose
but even so it's a terrible plan for
reasons that should already be clear but
will only become clearer as we keep
reading
it says waters plan has triggered
concern in the mortgage industry that uh
because it would require lenders to
identify and direct aid to
first-generation buyers
those whose parents don't own homes and
by the way i have
no idea how they would even identify
that group and it does
and they don't really have any idea how
they would either there isn't some
um database out there as far as i know
of americans who've never bought homes
before
anyway and it would also direct aid to
socially and economically disadvantaged
groups the move is also stirring broader
criticism about how much it would help
buyers and whether it would even put
them at risk
we are simply providing first-generation
home buyers largely people of color what
white first-time home buyers have been
receiving for years in the form of
the daddy down payment loan family
assistance that is almost never repaid
said david david dworkin president and
ceo of the national housing conference
and advocacy group the plan with the
most traction the 10 billion
proposal in a housing infrastructure
bill by waters would give state housing
finance
agencies grants to award up to twenty
thousand dollars in down payment
assistance to first-generation home
buyers
below a certain income threshold and up
to twenty-five thousand dollars if the
home buyer is from a socially
and economically disadvantaged group
waters bill includes the provision
alongside massive investments in public
housing and the national housing trust
fund
the bill defines socially disadvantaged
home buyers who would require or qualify
for larger credit
as individuals identifying as black
hispanic
native american or asian american
but such presumption may be rebutted
with credible evidence to the contrary
according to a discussion draft of the
legislation
so there it is if you didn't know any
better and you hear someone say that
they want to help the
socially disadvantaged you might think
that sounds like a fine idea
but then you learn that socially
disadvantaged is just a slightly more
sanitized way of saying
anyone who isn't white the plan here
isn't so much to help black people or
minorities it's to
not help white people they are after all
the only group left off the list even
asians are on the list of socially
disadvantaged
but asians have a higher median
household income than whites in this
country
asians are doing better than white
people and by a pretty significant
margin
whites are in fact more quote
disadvantaged
than asians the fact that they qualify
the asians that qualify for assistance
and white people don't proves if it
wasn't clear already
that the real point here is simply to
exclude whites
because they're white it's racist and
illegal
the constitution guarantees equal
protection under the law regardless of
race
laws that dole out perks based on race
while leaving whites in the cold are
unconstitutional by definition
now the argument that activists give for
this racist plan as you heard
is that white people have been getting
help from their parents
on their down payments and so it's only
fair if black people get help from the
government
the problem with that argument is first
of all not all white people have parents
who give them money to make down
payments
mine didn't i've bought three homes
i don't own three homes but we've moved
you know three times in the last four
years and i bought
homes in each place i didn't get any
help on any of those down payments
and besides here's a concept uh that
more people need to understand
the government is not your daddy there
are plenty of things that parents do
or can do which the government can't do
or shouldn't do and anyway whatever the
government is doing
it is it is racist and illegal to favor
certain groups based on race while
excluding others on the same basis
aside from the racial component though
the whole idea of down payment
assistance from the government
is catastrophically awful on its own
merits
even the race stuff aside a pretty good
general principle is this
if you can't afford to make a down
payment on a home
then you can't afford the home if you
need 25 grand from daddy government in
order to afford even just the down
payment
how are you going to pay your mortgage
going forward what about utilities
hoa fees if you have will you have money
to fix a leaky pipe or a broken hvac
unit
many expenses come with home ownership
believe me i'm
we're going through that right now as
people just recently bought a home
throwing people into homes they can't
afford all in the name of racial equity
is a disaster waiting to happen
especially now as the housing market is
challenging enough for buyers
it's very hard to find a house right now
again i know what i'm talking about
because the demand is through the roof
and the houses that are available are
all more expensive
expensive than they'd be in a normal
market and they're getting more
expensive every day
now throw a bunch of homeowners or
potential homeowners with a check from
the government into the mix
and you just made it harder for buyers
not easier more expensive not more
affordable
it's a bad idea on every level foolish
short-sighted
ridiculous also racist
exactly what we've come to expect from
maxine waters and friends
and that is why she is today of course
canceled
as she is every other day whether i say
it or not specifically
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nikka geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
the cdc is investigating possible heart
problems in young people brought on by
the covid vaccine dr fauci admits he was
wrong about the wuhan institute funding
and a liberal commentator wants to know
your favorite thing
about being white check it out on the
michael knowles show